it's good to be here it's surreal to be
here because I was sitting where you
guys are sitting three and a half years
ago and I could have not imagined being
invited to talk about my journey so
thanks for the invite really appreciate
it it's a little more useful and if I
were in your shoes which I was how this
would have been a little more efficient
so I'm not going to talk about capella
and I'm not gonna give you a marketing
presentation on what the company does
look up or come talk to me afterwards
happy to talk about it but how many of
you know about capella actually let me
just okay that's actually pretty good
I thought I would talk about very
quickly maybe just over 10 minutes of
the first few months of starting the
company and and give you a glimpse of
the stressful times than the and the
uncertainties that existed every day and
in those first six months and then
hopefully we can get into some Q&A and
dive deeper into any any any other
topics a little context on capella very
quickly we are trying to build an
infrastructure around our planet in
space using satellites in order to
monitor our planet and observe changes
believe it or not this doesn't really
really exist I mean we have certain
capabilities but they're a bunch of gaps
that that requires in my opinion to be
changed and the reason we started the
company was this how many of you
remember mh370 which was a Malaysian
flight going to China and it just
disappeared right I think this was
around 2014 I was at Stanford and
everyone was looking for this plane for
multiple weeks I mean I mean if you were
watching the news outlets this is all
that people were talking about it
crossed all the channels there were
multiple governments you know
superpowers China and US and Russia with
all of their assets looking for one
plane and it was not a small plane it
was a triple 7 with 280 passengers that
just went missing and we couldn't find
it and at that time we were thinking to
ourselves well why is that why is it
that we couldn't monitor that area and
why is it that on this one planet that
we call home such a big plane could go
missing and we have nothing that we
could do about it
and so we just started asking questions
of why is that what are we doing and how
are we doing and we thought it was
really important we thought monitoring
this one planet
in this one home that we have is really
really important so we started taking
classes at Stanford we took a class
called hacking for defense which was
taught by Steve Blank and it was all
about customer discovery our vision was
we want to live in a world where nothing
goes missing where we can monitor all
these important places around the world
and if something does go missing we can
go back and we can look at it so in
parallel outside to the class were sort
of doing technology development and
conceptual feasibility of can we
actually build a satellite that can do
that could see through through the
clouds can see at nighttime could it be
small enough that we could launch an
array of them and build a business out
of that we took a class with which Steve
Blank and it was all about customer
discovery and the class the question
you're asking in the class is imagine
you did build that so what who cares
about that what is the market what are
the opportunities what's the business
and after 10 weeks of pretty pretty
pretty tough challenges by Steve we
thought to ourselves that this would be
interesting and there's a big
opportunity in it so we went out and and
we decided to do fundraising and start
the company and I as I was kind of
thinking about this talk I dig my notes
and I found a whole bunch of pictures
from 3 years ago there's actually a
whiteboard that we in the venture studio
at GSB and we were trying to figure out
how much money we should raise and you
know it's like it's super high level
it's super basic looking back at it I'm
kind of sort of embarrassed but we're
like you know what if me raise 200k we
have one objective and our objective is
to essentially retire some of these risk
and then go back to investors and say
you know we did look at it we're the
right team and this is the right idea
and we know we know how to build this
thing and the major things that we
wanted to to de-risk and I think every
startup that starts these are the four
pillars that every investor is gonna
look at at the very beginning of the
company
one is the technology we're sorry for
the handwriting
one is the technology risk right is your
tech knowledge this technology actually
feasible to be built are you are you are
you dreaming of something that is
feasible or not and for that we wanted
to use our summer this was sort of a
three month period that we had
we wanted to use that summer and build a
small little prototype of the hardware
and fly it on a helicopter and
demonstrate that we could actually build
such a such a little prototype and
execute on it then there's the product
risk okay well for us the product and
the technology was slightly different
because we had to launch these
satellites capture imagery and then the
imagery had to turn into a product
well can you actually do that then there
was a market risk imagine you do have
the tech and you do have the right
product is there is this actually a big
enough market for venture a lot of
businesses are not and that's totally
fine but is this a big enough market for
venture so we wanted to talk to a bunch
of customers get letters of interest and
and show that if we did this people
would be interested in consuming this
type of imagery and information and then
there's the sort of company or risk or
steam risk which is is this the right
team who's going to be able to bring the
technology together execute on the
market and and make take this to the
finish line and then at that point like
early on in the company's life the
company risk the team risk is all about
the people and I had this one investor
that told me I am really not looking at
the business model because I know the
business model is going to change
everything that you're doing from now
until the final product how you get
there is going to be vastly different
than what you're proposing now I am
looking to figure out if this team is
the right team that when they hit the
wall and you know when things don't work
the way is intended to it does this team
have the ability to sort of go around it
and so by trying to do this over summer
and we raised about 200k we went out
raised up 200k and we wanted to retire
some of these risk we came back to the
venture studio super excited 200k in the
bank count never seen that big of a
money in my bank count let's plan out
the ten weeks and and and again like
apologies for the handwriting and some
of these are embarrassing when I look at
it now we even had this we had this
little orc chart up there and they're a
bunch of c-level positions which doesn't
really make sense
it was just three of us we were we're
trying to really figure out how do we
organize and how do we split these
responsibilities and what are the things
that we need to do over the next ten
weeks to get us to the finish line one
big lesson I learned from this was
nothing went as planned we we needed
more money we needed more time and none
of these weeks actually end up working
the way we planned it and and our story
this entire ten weeks was all about wow
we wanted to do that this first week
we're in week zero and we are not able
to make that happen what do we do now
and how do we go around that and we got
the money the first thing we did was we
went to Fry's and we bunched we bought a
whole bunch of electronics and the S
Fry's do still exist there's one in Palo
Alto and we start bred voting that's
that's that's my CTO right there in the
corner who was trying to build a little
breadboard and a little prototyping and
our goal was to build this little
prototype and fly it on a helicopter and
so we spend the next sort of six to
eight weeks trying to build that thing
and it was incredibly difficult it
doesn't look as complex as it should but
it was really really hard and I remember
this moment vividly this was probably
one of my most stressful days of my life
we had we were sort of at the very end
of trying to put this thing on a
helicopter we rented a helicopter for
the day and it was expended like five
hundred bucks a day we had it for the
entire day and you know when you have
like only 200k that's a lot of money we
showed up there and we wanted to just
one final test we before we put it up on
the helicopter and the thing wasn't
turning on it it was like oh my god this
is and every single problem you got it
you got a like put your single problem
was an existential problem you know
because it's like okay well I have a
limited amount of time I'm gonna run out
of money if we don't take it to that
finish line then we're done like there's
nothing what are we gonna do finally got
it working put it on the helicopter flew
this thing and realize oh snap actually
a helicopter is not the right way of
doing it because it's bouncing so much
and the the pilot can't really hold it
steady and the images are not going to
look that great
and this was literally like one week
before we had our deadline to meet with
investors and show them that we were the
right team and we had you know D risk
and retired all these other things that
we had been bragging about for ten weeks
and
we want we were super scrappy and we
went with a Cessna and we had this super
sketchy box at the bottom that we wanted
to strap around the wings of the Cessna
and put our instrument in there and fly
it no one in their right mind wanted to
do that I mean we went to every single
Airport within the within hundred miles
of here and we wouldn't like no one
wanted to do that so we found this
little tiny Airport bless their heart
love them to death and the guy was like
yeah I'll do it for you guys you know
you look like students they're doing
some cool stuff he did we flew this
thing we went up we took our imagery as
we were coming down
we kind of crash-landed the pilot wasn't
really that good and it kind of explains
why he was totally down to do this so we
crash-landed we were obviously okay
super stressful time and we ran out of
the runway and then they had to call a
pickup truck to come to come grab us
this I mean I hadn't thought about this
for almost three years because life has
just been so fast but the crazy thing
isn't that we crashed the crazy thing is
we came back home we looked up the data
we weren't really happy with the data so
we called the guy and we decided to go
on the same plane the next day to do
more collection and I didn't tell my mom
I think she's gonna watch this later
sorry anyway so I went back and we did
the collection it worked out it was
great actually I have a little video of
Mima and my co-founder sitting in the
pickup truck that's towing the the the
plane and I thought would be with the
fully broken
anyway we had a good time we did make it
to the fundraising meeting and we were
able to raise money and now it's three
years later and I want to show you a
video of our first launch of our first
satellite which happened in December
December 4th where a company or about 60
people now headquarters in San Francisco
we've raised more than 50 million of
venture from good investors around here
and this was the moment where we
launched our first satellite and we were
seeing the rocket getting lifted up and
in our satellite getting deployed and if
you're working on something like this
for three years it is like your baby and
it's very very emotional for everyone
who's involved so let's watch this
Apollo space headquarter in San
Francisco and we built a satellite and
our satellite is sitting on top of
Falcon 9 and Vandenberg right now it's
about to launch 5 4 3 2
through the hardest part for just
getting there the next one is making
initial contact
[Music]
[Applause]
we had our first contact and satellite
we received the beacon and it shows that
the solar panel has been deployed
successfully so that was a big big first
success all right
well things are a little easier but the
road is really really really bumpy
because we we are still super super
early stage but it's been a fun right
and I'm excited to get into a little
more conversation about it you know it's
an interesting thing about space in
general right it's still one of these
areas that can still capture the human
imagination in a way that other things
can how did you fall in love with space
when was this when did this happen for
you I was involved with this the most
nerdy non-athletic program called
astronomy Olympia and it has nothing to
do with the Olympia that you might think
it's it's bunch of high school kids who
are passionate about stars and how
universe and galaxies are formed and how
they collide and how satellites go
around and we would throw these these
star parties and again it has nothing to
do with the party that you might imagine
we would go in the middle of the desert
with telescopes and we would look at the
stars and try to map them and we would
compete there was like serious
competition between different high
schools on who could remember or
recognize more names and who had better
equations figured out to solve problems
and at some point I realized astronomy
wasn't my my best I wasn't as science II
I was more of an engineer so I switched
into aerospace but but I think it's not
that hard to look at space and totally
get you know fascinated because there's
so much that we don't know you know what
am I
Rico says somewhere out there some
somewhere out there something incredibly
incredible is happening it's waiting to
be discovered and we're so lucky to be
able to be part of that that it's funny
to talk about things that people don't
know yet and the piece of discovery what
is the general public actually not
understand about trying to create a
business that involves being in space I
mean what's different about that
well they say space is hard and they
really mean it you know if 10 years ago
you thought about starting a space
business it was just unthinkable right
because you had to be a space agency of
the government or a country and you had
to build everything from scratch right
you have to build your ground stations
and the network and the dishes and you
know rockets were super limited and and
you have to build every single little
piece that's going to go into your
satellite to take it up now it's quite
different I mean over the last seven
years I would say there's an entire
ecosystem built around space and I think
majority of the public here about SpaceX
which is fantastic but there's so many
companies that are attacking and
grabbing different parts of the supply
chain whether it's you know companies
trying to build just pieces and parts
that goes into the satellite whether
it's companies that are building dishes
that then allows these satellite
companies to receive data whether it's
companies that are doing storage or
analytics or companies like us we're
building the satellite and the payload
itself there are so many commercial
companies out there where now as a
commercial provider you can come in and
you can specialize on just one piece
without really needing to build
everything else around it and that's
creating this sort of massive movement
that we're seeing on on entrepreneurs
jumping on the space opportunities and
you couple that with the fact that space
has been traditionally in in sort of in
hands of governments and and these
agencies who are extremely risk-averse
and as a result there are technologies
that just never made it to that to that
sort of side of the fence we have some
customers we have some competitors if
you want to order imagery from them you
have to fax them like you have to
physically have a fax in 2019 and
be able to fax them to get an image
right and so the opportunity to do a
thousand X improvement as it happen
already in software hasn't happened yet
in space and and so I think that's
attracting not only a lot of investments
but also a lot of entrepreneurs and and
people who have good ideas on how to do
things slightly different and so I think
it's changing but you know the the
perception of how space has been over
the last 10 years is gonna be
drastically different ten years from now
- it's really kind of encouraging
because you think about something is
even aerospace engineering is even this
sort of separate field a lot of people
will probably go out I'm not going to be
able to do that or hack that so I'm
gonna go do something else but there's
opportunities to be had there I mean you
did your undergraduate in aerospace and
you came here to Stanford and got a
master's here in management science
engineering a being that you saw
opportunities why management science and
engineering and versus maybe an MBA or
something like that well so I I didn't
want to do ever space again so I
actually came in as a master student for
aerospace and I decided to switch to
missiny because I thought I had a pretty
solid aerospace background and what I
didn't understand is business and I
didn't understand you know Finance and
Accounting and fundraising and what does
what does it mean to start a company
what is a company I didn't know any of
that stuff and I did think about GSP
versus Emma Snee Emma sandy made a lot
of sense to me mostly because it's such
an open-ended program where you can
build your own journey and you can take
whatever classes that you think fits the
specific needs that you have so I had a
whole bunch of Emma singing students who
are deep into finance right now working
at hedge funds I have some that are deep
into computer science and our product
managers and I have some that are doing
supply chain and operations and then I
have some other ones who started
companies and all of them took the same
degree and but but the outcome of degree
was quite different and so I liked the
sort of unstructured and the SUNY
program it was also quite cheaper than
an MBA so from the return of investment
standpoint it made
we were the value price offer I'm very
excited to hear that I'm sure our our
friends across the street achieve it I
mean we've had speakers coming here
before who were alums and they talked
about like a critical component of the
Stanford experience is okay the course
is a great faculty is great you know the
environments great but like it's the
side projects it's those little things
that you carve the time out for we're
all the kind of collective passions
smash into each other I mean you took
advantage of a bunch of different things
here you mentioned venture studio
earlier you were also a fellow and our
dfj kind of master's program what did
you get from those sorts of experiences
that yeah I would say it's the side
projects all the all the classes and
programs as well as the people right I
mean they're as you're just walking
across campus you just get inspired by
meeting random people that are also
doing really interesting stuff but then
classes specifically the dfj and some of
these other programs that I took allowed
me to kind of know the way for
fundraising specifically allowed me to
have more confidence as I'm talking to
an investor because I knew what they
were looking for and what the process is
like and and most importantly allowed me
to create a network and connections to
then when I actually didn't want to
raise money I had a few people that I
could reach out and I had a bit of an
experience on on how to how to do that
and so I think you know you will hear
this from the GSB MBA students is one of
the best bang for the buck that they get
is they build a great network of people
right and so when they leave Stanford
they've got this sort of almost like a
family in core group that they can reach
out and I really tried to build the same
thing even though I wasn't part of GSB
and that was you know just take as many
of the classes meet as many of the
people and be able to to build a
foundation where I could you know I
could not only give it back but also
receive something if I needed to
it's interesting you kind of mentioned
the community aspect of that being
important and I mean in your career you
know you had this opportunity if I
understood correctly you know you worked
at a NASA JPL and you know Jet
Propulsion lab down south and it's like
iconic place you know in this field what
about that environment did you you know
you spend enough time there to kind of
know what are things that existed in
that world
that you have taken to capella and maybe
what's something not that it's
inherently good or bad but you just
decided that's not for us that's for
them yeah so JBL is a magical place that
it builds all the all essentially robots
that we've ever sent into into into
space the one that you guys might be
familiar with is the Mars rover the
Curiosity rover that landed I believe in
2000 and maybe a 12 just magical place
and and I think you know I obviously
learned a lot of aerospace there and
processes and management but what I took
away that most was this mentality that
anything is possible and it's just it's
just an engineering challenge and so if
there is someone that wants something we
can make it happen and that was so much
of the mentality at JPL I mean for God's
sake we built a rover that was one-ton
and we used the sky crane to to
literally put it down on the surface of
Mars right like who imagines that and
then and then who can actually build
that so I guess my my entrepreneurial
reality the store shouldn't came from
JPL and that was really helpful I
thought anything in the world is
possible and and and you do need a
little bit of sort of knave ignorant
thinking when you're starting a company
that's what I took away and there's
stuff that I didn't take away right so
gpo what I didn't take away from there
is the sense of perfectionism and
anything that JPL builds needs to be
perfect and it needs to work the first
time and and if it takes those ten years
and three billion dollar to do it
we will do it that way but it will be a
perfect product and I lift that right
there
and so what we do at capella is we try
not to be perfect and we try to be
quicker and we try to hit to bring sort
of this what's been known in the
software industry as Hydra software into
hardware and aerospace which is really
really difficult but you know what if
the first one doesn't work the way that
the ultimate product you know I'm going
to learn so much more through that
process and it's gonna cost cheaper and
it's gonna be faster and and so that's
something that can I left left behind at
JPL I mean you've had this experience
now three years in you know founding and
founding with a team together is really
interesting but you're in this role as
CEO as well what is the what is actually
the best part about being CEO because
everyone always use the pictures about
how hard and difficult it is and
challenging but what's something that's
really liked that you thrive on that's
exciting about that role and maybe
something that's been let's say more
surprising this surprising the
challenging part is also at the same
time really exciting part is that
usually only problems make it all the
way to the top and so you know if a
problem is solved you're probably not
going to hear from it and and the
problems that do get to the top are
problems that weren't able to get solved
and so you're always on a day to day
basis trying to solve problems that are
really really difficult across multiple
multiple departments and some of them
are existential problems especially as
an early-stage startup company and on a
daily basis you're trying to put out
fire of course as you're building the
company you're becoming more stable
fully there's less of that but I think
you know as a CEO that's been one of the
most stressful parts of the job and then
this sort of you know sheer amount of
responsibility that you feel and I feel
towards my team because when we started
the company was just me and my
co-founder it was just the two of us
right we're doing this for ourselves and
you know we'll see where it goes who
knows where where it's gonna go but then
now we're 60 people and people have
families and some of them we recruited
them from out of state and they're moved
here because of us and so it's not just
about me anymore right it's it's about
people's careers and their their beliefs
and their you know their confidence and
nots to make something happen of this
and so that's pretty stressful I think
what I love about the job the most is
the ability to change I think one of the
one of the most important personalities
of a founder or CEO in a fast-growing
startup is ability to adapt and be able
to change very frequently because you
know the CEO of a two-person company and
a 10% and at 30 and 50 and then hundred
is gonna be a vastly different job and
there are different responsibilities and
if you're not able to adapt to the new
roles and new requirements and grow with
the company then it's gonna be really
difficult but I have sort of taken that
apart and has changed me personally at a
personal level but has changed me at a
professional level and I've really
enjoyed kind of you know seeing that
change over the last three years do you
find that that something that then you
are and your team is looking for when
you're hiring and stuff are you looking
for that same adaptability and agility
and the people that you bring in or are
you looking for other things to
complement that that's yeah it's it's
critical I mean you know when we were a
company of 10 right the culture was
different it was a lot more agile and
you know the way we were just doing
things there was there's no org chart
there was no handbook there was no
process there was we're just doing
things as a team
there was one credit card we were
literally using as a team okay you need
to order that go for it you know and as
the company has changed and grown all
those processes have changed because
they were not scaleable anymore and I
think one of my important roles as a CEO
is to reiterate to my team that changed
is okay and change is actually not only
okay but the highly desired and because
you know they've changed is difficult
right like I mean if you're used to a
certain certain way then all of a sudden
you know everything's changing then
you're kind of
what happened and so I try to infuse
that to the team there you know every
two weeks every all-hands talking about
how this did changed we used to do it
that way we're doing it this way but
that's totally fine this is how it's
supposed to be and and I think if you're
trying to join a start-up you got to
enter the environment knowing that
everything is gonna change very soon and
so I've told people if something is not
working today it will most likely be
faced three months from now so let's
just work it out let's just get together
talk about it because they're a bunch of
stuff that it's not working right at me
and said it's growing pains of you know
building it building a company that's
growing really fast and so if you're not
okay would change it's gonna be
difficult and so we certainly look into
that when we're hiring new people you
use this wonderful example early on in
the presentation about the Malaysia air
flight and I imagine you know we've
heard repeatedly from people about the
things the reasons that someone might go
to work for a company right why this
place versus this where do you find your
connection your why about that places
mission what are some of the things
either through the years where you were
talking to prospective customers and
things like that what are some of the
use cases you see from a social
perspective that successfully being able
to use this technology getting enough
satellites in space to build that kind
of network of visibility what are some
other examples that you see in maybe
different sectors or something of impact
in that way yeah so I mean we're excited
about a whole bunch of markets when it
comes to building a sustainable business
insurance finance maritime security
agriculture but when I step back and I
think about some of the big problems
that we're having here on earth as
species you know you can't not realize
that a lot of our problems are our very
global problems right I mean if you
compare us to you know a thousand years
ago in some African tribe in the Indus
ara desert they really didn't care about
the politics of Asia or conflicts in
Middle East or deforestation in Amazon
probably didn't even know that it
existed right but now we're living in a
world where an events happening in u.s.
you know policies of US politics of Asia
and the conflicts of of Middle East
and and and some of these other problems
are highly connected and they influence
everyone they impact everyone and so
it's a much more globalized world that
we're living in and in such a globalized
world our problems are also going to be
at a global level as opposed to sort of
these isolated problems no nuclear
challenge technological advancement and
how that's going to affect us all and
most importantly that's close to my
heart is ecological and climate change
and so in a world where everything is so
globalized I think we do need a
capability as species to be able to look
at the globe and understand when
something happens across you know in
Brazil how does that actually impact
Southeast Asia when something does
happen in North Pole how does that
actually impact Europe and be able to
connect the dot dots and the lakes and
and building an infrastructure in space
which by definition and by nature is a
very global observation I think it's
going to be really critical and if you
just pick sort of the climate change
problem that we're going to be facing we
know that there's going to be more
extreme weather right we know and we're
seeing some of that already there's
going to be more tornadoes there's going
to be more hurricanes there's going to
be rising water oceans there are going
to be people that are gonna be displaced
there's gonna be more migrations there's
going to be agriculture production
issues these are issues that we will
have and even if we today tried to solve
climate change some of these were
already seen and so in that type of a
world I think again it's really critical
for us to have a non-terrestrial based
right because those things are gonna get
destroyed capability and infrastructure
where as things are happening in London
or in Houston Texas or in Singapore we
have eyes in the sky to monitor as it's
happening to help people move to
understand the damages and then
ultimately be able to to look at how our
planet is changing over time so I think
it's a capability that we should have at
species and
we want to be part of that there's
really kind of a very beautiful call to
that it makes you think of sort of like
the first pictures of Earth from space
right you know this sort of collective
sense that was not available to people
before because they didn't know it
existed they didn't have it I mean
you're running a business as well here
and commerce is a part of that how do
you when you go to like go for customers
in this space what is sort of the
strategies here I mean we've had folks
who've developed apps or they've got
other sorts of businesses of all
different stripes that they've affected
on what is the customer development
process like in terms of like going out
in your team your beedi team how do you
approach that what did you have before
that you still use now those sorts of
things yeah it's it's because we're
building a capability that's never
existed before it means the market also
doesn't exist for for that you know
capability and so that we have the
company's sales team sort of divided
into business development for new
markets those are markets don't really
exist but we believe that once the
capability goes up they're a bunch of
really interesting thing we do and then
the sort of sales to the market that
does exist and use imagery and they've
been using and turns out this market is
mostly a government market because
governments you know they're used to
this stuff there's got a 30 year head
start the first imaging satellite was
launched a long time ago week ono-san
and so they know how to use satellites
and how to use imagery and and the
government should need to be able to
look at a lot of a lot of areas and so
this is more of a sales cycle you know
we're coming with a new capability but
the requirements are well-defined and
customers customers are there and it's a
very traditional sells whereas this new
one the business development is is very
much so it we're approaching it from
bottoms up and tops down so we're doing
a sort of a very similar to what we did
at Steve blanks class a proper customer
discovery where we go on and we talk to
people we we we try to really understand
their problems and the typical questions
we ask there is you know when we're
talking to a CIO chief
formation officer or CTO you know you
ask questions like what keeps you up at
night like what are the things that you
know if you had five million dollar of
an R&D budget where would you spend it
and with you know through those
conversations we're trying to figure out
what are like fundamental problems that
these guys have and and then we come
back and we we try to see if we can
solve them and you know one big thing I
learned from Steve's class was you never
bias the conversation right so you don't
you never show up and say I've got this
great capability would you use it
because because then you've immediately
biased them if you can if they tell you
their problem and it turns out that your
solution could solve the problem
jack-bots right because now you've got a
customer that didn't know that you had
this but they told you that that was the
problem and so for the beady side on the
new markets there's a lot of
conversations and these different
markets and we're quite organized about
them and and you know we go to
agriculture and the farmers and we tried
to categorize and go and try to create
those markets but creating a new market
is very difficult and it takes a long a
long time because you got a roll out the
product you got a demo it you go to
demonstrate that is actually useful to
them it's going to move the bottom line
and then you got to figure out how are
you gonna blend yourself into this
workflow that they've had for many years
and so it will take us a while to get
there on the new market but we're super
excited about bunch of use cases we've
found and meanwhile while we're doing
that we're going to work with some of
these existing markets which are mostly
around government's it's interesting
like you think about the comparisons
between a small firm and a large from in
this space and you know you think of
traditional players and companies
enormous research and development
budgets and stuff how does capella do
research and development or are you just
busy like we got to get these first
however many it is what's the total
number for the network and the first
sort of simply 36 36 is it just dear God
just get the 36 up or is it there is
some space that's already kind of
looking beyond that yeah that's a
classic startup problem like there are
too many things that you want to do but
you don't have all the resources to do
it so how do you have you put them on a
list and rank them but you know I think
you know a couple things I think about a
lot one is when we talk about our art
sort of competitors
they're massive companies you know big
ships one of our competitor competitive
advantages that they're a big ship and
it will take them a long time before
they can actually do this and we'll take
them a lot of resources before they can
change the you know the the direction of
the ship and then when we use that as a
competitive manner so the question is
how do we not how do we make sure we
don't fall into the same trap and some
other startup doesn't come in three
years from now and say you know what
these guys are a big ship we've come up
with this really new technology that's
10x better than them and we're gonna
disrupt those how do we not get
disrupted and I think if you're too
focused on just your v1 product then
you're gonna miss develop and so even
though you know we're only launch one
satellite and we haven't rolled out all
of the other satellites that we want to
do we do spend you know five ten percent
of our our resources on thinking about
the next iteration whether it's you know
the cells and the BD and the marketing
team talking to customers and kind of
bringing all that feedback into to
capella and and then we sort of analyze
and say okay well we can't do this with
this product but it seems like we're
getting a lot of feedback on this and we
should add it to the next feature or
we're just having you know some
interesting rnd that we're doing on our
own and so you see where it goes I think
it's really important to allocate a
little bit of budget and resources on
doing that early on and build a culture
of that right because I mean you know
when we launch 36 satellite it's not
like we're gonna be done and we just we
have to keep the engine going so I think
it's really important but it's all about
the balance right how much of this do
you do versus that and I mentioned
you're still getting kind of feedback
did you go out to customers there's new
things that keep appearing right in that
same frame I mean when you guys first
sort of identified you know where the
pain points were I mean you did
something sort of interesting and I'm
gonna go deep out of my technical depth
here so save me if I fall but the
synthetic aperture radar technology has
been around how long had that technology
been around for a long time 40 years 40
years yeah so was it something that you
saw sitting there on the shelf that's
like cheese why isn't nobody using this
or was it something about no it's just a
lack of the continuous reliable imaging
what was the first kind of understanding
that the hint that's the first strongest
hint you got from those cuffs yes sorry
has been around as I said
time and it's mostly been used as a
military and government tool right
because it's a it's the way works is
it's a radar imaging system and so we
can see through clouds you can see at
nighttime so it's a sort of a very
reliable imaging system and and honestly
I you know the vision was we want to
build a constellation of 36 satellites
in order to monitor places every hour or
better and in order to do that these
satellites need to be really small and
then and then the problems were okay
well all these satellites are really big
so how are we going to make them small
and this is where the sort of the the
the glutton delusional founder comes in
and the reality distortion comes in and
we're like well we think we can actually
build a really big structure that can
fit in a tiny little box but then once
it goes up in space it's just bump just
deploys itself and people have probably
thought about that for a long time but
no one no one believes themselves that's
possible and so we believe that
ourselves we thought we thought we had
it and so we saw an opportunity I mean
we did a whole bunch of design and we
thought it was doable but we thought
that you know it is it is it is totally
doable and and people are not doing it
because they're afraid of the potential
risks that are involved and and the hard
work that you gotta put in so far it's
worked out pretty good yeah please help
me thank you for coming to the talk
today